[Música]
desde que era pequeño siempre creí y
siempre supe que de cierta manera podría
cambiar el mundo esto lo escuchamos
muchas veces en frases en personajes
pero realmente qué significa cambiar el
mundo y cómo lo podemos lograr sin darme
cuenta años más tarde estuve
representando estudiantes de medicina de
todo el mundo hablando con ministros de
salud
proponiendo proyectos a nivel mundial
pero si ahora me preguntan cómo llegué o
cómo se puede cambiar el mundo
sinceramente no tengo una respuesta
clara y no lo sé pero tengo algunas
recomendaciones de cómo se puede llegar
a este paso
durante mi carrera de medicina cuando
una de las federaciones más increíbles y
fm sea es la asociación y la federación
internacional de asociaciones de
estudiantes de medicina
esta federación fue fundada en 1951
después de la segunda guerra mundial y
rep es y representa a más de 1.3
millones de estudiantes de ciencias de
la salud en todo el mundo está se
encuentra en más de 127 países en las
cinco regiones y en el verano del 2017
después de haber trabajado aquí en la
universidad haber trabajado
nacionalmente con la asociación de
estudiantes me presenté como candidato
en arusha tanzania
y sin darme cuenta que de electo como
director mundial de educación médica de
esta federación esta federación se
encarga de la representación estudiantil
de dar una voz internacionalmente en
asambleas en reuniones y sobre todo
empoderar estudiantes para para la toma
de decisiones y para poder realizar
acciones que tengan un impacto pero si
algo concluir es que la manera en la que
se puede cambiar el mundo es mediante la
representación estudiantil significativa
o meaning future moment ésta es una
filosofía es una filosofía estudiantil
en la cual cualquier estudiante o
cualquier persona joven puede
involucrarse en el proceso de
aprendizaje y tener acciones
significativas pero ustedes dirán estos
en medicina estos en ciencias de la
salud cómo se aplica para mí de hecho
sin importar qué carrera ustedes
estudian o hayan estudiado
se trata de desarrollar ciertas
características de aptitudes liderazgo
pensamiento crítico ser profesionales
innovadores pero en mayor o menor medida
que ustedes presenten estas
características se puede lograr ser un
representante estudiantil siguiendo unos
sencillos pasos
en primer lugar lo que yo me pregunte es
que ser representante estudiantil porque
uno puede ser elegido puede ser votado
puede ser designado e incluso sorteado
pero el tener un cargo no significa que
uno realmente está representando uno
tiene que estar seguro que lo que uno
está trabajando por hablando por es en
realidad la representación de quienes
están junto a ustedes entonces yo me
pregunte quién puede ser un
representante estudiantil y es muy fácil
cualquier estudiante puede ser un
representante pero obviamente esto
dependerá mucho de las personalidades
que tenemos dependerá de cuánto tiempo
extra ustedes quieren invertir en su
carrera o en su profesión a la
representación o al liderazgo
estudiantil sin importar qué
características o de las aptitudes
anteriores ustedes posean ustedes pueden
ir desarrollando para llegar a ser
líderes locales nacionales o incluso
mundiales
y que van a representar yo no les voy a
decir qué es lo que ustedes tienen que
representar porque cambia mucho de área
a área pero lo que sí les puedo decir es
que tienen que representar algo que
ustedes estén apasionados y realmente
crean cuando
no hay un momento ideal para ser
representante obviamente en algunas
circunstancias ustedes tendrán más voz
tendrán más y sus acciones serán más
reflejadas pero si algo ha aprendido es
que la representación estudiantil y la
voz estudiantil es importante y algo que
también descubrí es que los adultos las
empresas los gobiernos quieren saber qué
quiere que tiene que decir la juventud
entonces no crean que hay momentos
específicos donde ustedes pueden ser
líderes de la juventud ustedes pueden
hacerlo en cualquier momento por ejemplo
en si algo ha descubierto es que en los
momentos de acreditación en los procesos
de acreditación de las instituciones hay
gran apertura para el cambio estudiantil
ustedes pueden llegar ahí con propuestas
con nuevos cambios y se pueden realizar
donde no importa si lo van a hacer en su
universidad en su clase en su facultad o
incluso a mayor nivel lo importante es
que esto se empiece a hacer desde su
localidad desde el ambiente donde
ustedes es donde ustedes son capaces de
influir y lo más importante el cómo
he descubierto que hay ciertas
herramientas y hay mucha literatura que
habla al respecto de cómo ser un buen
líder o cómo ser un líder estudiantil en
cualquier ambiente
la primera es encontrar aliados
estratégicos llámense profesores
autoridades gobiernos ongs pero se
necesita que nosotros tengamos un
sistema de apoyo en el cual la voz
estudiantil la voz de la juventud pueda
ser escuchada a mayor nivel esto se
puede realizar encontrando
organizaciones encontrando asociaciones
incluso con la misma universidad
hablando con las personas correctas la
segunda y es de mis mayores aprendizajes
es el crear equipos y tener un buen
liderazgo
el ser líder es muy difícil decir que se
nace porque estas habilidades se van
adquiriendo durante este año como
director mundial y yo formé un equipo de
9 personas de 9 países diferentes de 5
regiones y si algo aprendí es que la
diversidad es una de las mejores
herramientas que tenemos muchas veces
decir tenemos distintas culturas
distintos pensamientos creencias nos van
a llevar para atrás pues no es difícil
no voy a mentir lo es difícil pero
mientras uno esté abierto a aceptar la
crítica constructiva el feedback uno
puede ir creciendo como representante y
como líder y no necesariamente crean que
por tener el puesto o por tener
cualquier puesto de liderazgo ustedes
van a estar siempre a la cabeza déjense
ayudar eso es muy importante el tercer
punto sería el hacer actividades con
evidencia cualquier actividad proyecto
que ustedes hacen tiene que estar
fundamentado
es decir si ustedes quieren realizar un
proyecto a gran escala tiene que tener
unas bases sólidas
científicas por ejemplo nosotros para
trabajar en educación médica realizamos
una encuesta mundial de cómo funcionan
las escuelas de medicina en todo el
mundo tuvimos más de 80 respuestas de
370 estudiantes y con esto nosotros
pudimos ver cuáles son las falencias que
tienen las distintas escuelas de
medicina en el mundo como están siendo
tratados los estudiantes cómo pueden
intervenir más los estudiantes para
tener acciones de mayor impacto y
finalmente yo diría de las más
importantes es tener pasión cuando uno
trabaja por pasión en este tipo de
actividades estudiantiles en el tipo de
actividades de liderazgo uno se da
cuenta que puede invertir cuán voy a
invertir este tiempo que se requiere
cuando en verdad la pasión y cuando uno
habla con pasión tiene más credibilidad
tiene más confianza
algo que puedo llevarme de esta
experiencia trabajando en esta
federación que se utiliza mucho esta
frase es piensa globalmente actúa
localmente esta es una foto de la última
asamblea que fue en canadá si ustedes
pueden fijarse la diversidad de
estudiantes que habían y como antes les
estaban mencionando la diversidad es un
plus que nosotros podemos utilizar en
nuestra ventaja
al pensar globalmente nosotros empezamos
a adquirir conocimientos ideas de cómo
resolver un problema que tal vez no
sabíamos cómo resolverlo en nuestra
localidad e implementarlo en nuestra
propia realidad entonces no importa en
qué sector ustedes estén trabajando se
están trabajando en su universidad están
trabajando en una organización de su
país lo importante es que sepan cómo
cortar estas ideas globales e
implementarlas en un sistema local en su
entorno directo entonces para
recapitular
no importa si ustedes están trabajando
para su clase están trabajando para su
universidad para una organización o en
su país o si ya son profesionales están
trabajando en su entorno hay tres
características que se tienen que llevar
y como juventud es importante que sepan
que puedan que pueden utilizarlas para
hacer cambios positivos
la primera es del empoderamiento yo les
mostré algunas herramientas pero
obviamente según su carrera según su
propio entorno podrán ir adquiriendo
nuevas herramientas para empoderarse
saber cómo tienen que utilizar su
ambiente en el favor en su favor para
realizar el cambio el segundo es crear
equipos y ser un libre
cambiar el mundo es difícil pero no se
puede hacer solo y por último es la
pasión no importa porque quien usted es
empoderar porque quieren luchar porque
quieren dar voz pero si es algo que les
apasiona que ustedes están convencidos
que debe ser así háganlo porque
utilizando estas tres características
estoy seguro que este sueño que yo tuve
de niño de cambiar el mundo puede
hacerlo cualquiera así que vamos a
juventud que nosotros en verdad podemos
cambiar el mundo muchas gracias
[Aplausos]